JENNY BLAKE: Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
It's really an honor to be back,
and it's so exciting for me.
It's one of my
messages in the book.
That "PIVOT," and our
jobs, and the economy,
it's so fluid now
that this, to me,
is really a joy, that
even though I left Google
as a full time employee, to
still come back, and partner,
and talk, and be here.
As I was reflecting
on what would
be most meaningful
to share today,
it occurred to me that
to the outside world,
hitting a pivot point
or plateau at Google
is a bit of an oxymoron.
You should be nothing but 100%
fulfilled and 100% grateful
100% of the time.
Hashtag blessed.
But in some ways, it's its
own first world career problem
that we feel that there's
something wrong with us
if we hit a plateau or a pivot
point, and very naturally
start asking, what's next?
What's next within my role?
Within the company?
Within my broader career,
where am I trying to go?
And we start to internalize
some of this shame
and blame that I think we
feel from the outside world.
Like, you're so lucky, I
would kill for that job.
And I used to get this a lot.
And I don't know if any of you
going to parties or meeting
someone at a conference--
the first question
is, what's the food like?
Or what's the culture like?
And all of a sudden, it
seems unreasonable to talk
about what's really going
on and how you might really
be feeling.
And that it goes in
very natural ways.
What's interesting
is that I still
am experiencing this,
even 5 and 1/2 years out.
I left Google.
I started in 2006, as the
company had 6,000 employees,
and was here as
it grew to 36,000.
And when my first
book was coming out,
I left to go all in, and
give myself six months
to see if I could make it.
And here I am 5 and
1/2 years later.
Not without its ups and downs.
But I'll give an example of this
kind of judgment that comes.
So one of the early
reviews for the book
came in Success
Magazine, and this is
before the book was even out.
And the reporter
writes, how ironic is it
that a career development
manager at Google's much envied
Career Guru program
hit a career plateau
and needed to take a sabbatical?
I'll play that back for you.
She says, how ironic is it that
a career development program
manager at Google's much
envied Career Guru program
hit a career plateau and
needed to take a sabbatical?
At first, I thought,
ouch, that stings.
And then I realized
you should want nothing
less of the teams working
here on career development,
and Career Guru, and
internal coaching
than for them to be asking
these big questions.
So I don't find
it ironic at all.
I actually think
it's really important
that we think about and
consider what's next.
And Career Guru is something
that I'm very passionate about.
Becky and I worked on this
together during our time here.
And the mission was to
provide drop in coaching
for any Googler, so
that if people wanted
to talk about their career in a
safe, neutral way-- we always,
of course, are encouraging
talking to your manager,
but also to have a space
to think about what's next.
And before we go
any further, let
me just say that
pivoting-- sometimes people
get the wrong impression
from the book title,
that it always means drastic
career changes, changing
your career completely.
That's not it at all.
So a pivot is inherently one
related thing into the next.
And you can even pivot
within your role.
So as I wrote this book
and started researching it,
it's really a
mindset and a method
for mapping your next move.
I'll share some context
and what I discovered
in working on this
book, and then there
will be some time for
you to reflect today too.
Because ultimately,
pivots are very personal.
And not only is there
nothing wrong with you
if you've hit a pivot
point or plateau,
but that's as to be expected.
In fact, and especially
at a company like Google,
hitting a pivot point is
a product of your success.
It means that you've
acclimated to the role
that you're in and the
nature of the tasks
that are a part of your role,
and now you're very naturally
looking to say, OK, what else?
Give me more.
How else can I grow here?
When I started
unpacking this question,
first, I had two main questions.
One, how can people be
as agile as startups?
And then two, how do we get
better at asking and answering
this question, what's next?
So a little bit
about my background.
I was working at a
startup out of college.
In fact, I was studying
political science,
took a leave of absence to work
with a professor at a startup
as the first employee.
One of my roles, maybe
5% to 10% of my role,
was managing our Google
adverts accounts.
And when I hit a
plateau there, I
moved over to Google on their
adverts product training team.
The career conversation
that I regret the most
is the one I never had, and
that was with the founder
of the startup.
That instead of telling him,
I've hit a plateau here,
what else can we do?
How can I grow in my role?
I started interviewing
for Google
in my car on lunch breaks.
But I ended up so thankful to
get that role on the training
and development team.
Two years in, I hit
another pivot point.
And once again, at
that point, I really
thought something
was wrong with me.
I'm at Google.
I'm at the Disneyland
of companies.
What's wrong here?
And my role had shifted.
I become a manager,
I was working
on a lot of PowerPoint
strategy decks.
And I felt like there was
some element that was missing.
So thankfully, because
of a serendipitous
run in with Becky Cotton
in the parking lot,
she said, you know, there's this
career development team forming
and there's a role open.
You should apply for it.
And now I see Steve.
Hi, good to see you.
And so I applied
and I got the role,
because I'd been working
on a 10% project with Becky
to try and bring drop
in coaching to Google.
And then sure enough,
about a year or two later,
I hit another pivot point.
The book was coming
out, I was working
around the clock, both at Google
and then nights and weekends
on my own thing.
And at that point,
I realized-- I
did take a sabbatical, my ironic
sabbatical that the reporter so
nicely described.
And I had every
intention of coming back.
But once I was on
the road, I realized
it's not going to be
fair to either Google
or to my own projects if I give
them both the short shrift.
If I spread myself too thin,
I'm just going to hit burn out
and not be effective
anywhere to anyone.
So at that point, I
made the tough decision
to go all in on my own thing
and see if I could do it.
And so I gave myself six months.
And for the first
year and a half,
I rode the adrenaline of that.
Like OK, I can do this.
I'm not going to prove
everybody right who
said you're crazy to
leave, you're an idiot,
how are you going
to feed yourself?
And so I kind of poured
everything into my business
until once again, a year and
a half after leaving Google,
I was asking, what's next?
I had written "Life
After College."
On podcasts and
in interviews, I'd
become the girl who left Google.
That was all anyone
wanted to talk about,
was what I had left behind.
And I was really confused
about what lies ahead.
What do I stand for?
What can I create content
and a mission around?
How can I be most
helpful to people?
Who am I?
And this time, I didn't
have a steady paycheck
to fund that exploration.
So as my bank account
dwindled down to zero,
many of my biggest fears
about leaving Google
were coming true.
I didn't know how I was going
to pay the rent in two weeks.
And that was really different
than every other time
in my career where I
had asked, what's next?
At that point, the
question is not,
what do you do if you
knew you couldn't fail,
but what do you do when your
back is up against the wall?
And I knew I could
either solve this,
and I pretty much had
two weeks to do it,
or I would have to leave New
York or go get another job.
And while neither of those
things is categorically bad,
it just didn't feel like
the right thing for me.
So in that moment, I came
to one of two conclusions.
Either there's something
really wrong with me,
and I'm destined to be
unhappy in my career,
and I keep asking what's
next every few years,
and there's a problem here,
and I will forever be unhappy--
and I felt ungrateful.
I felt ungrateful for hitting
these points within Google
and now outside of it.
What is it going to be?
I hadn't clicked into my
skis yet, if you will.
But the second conclusion
was that this feeling
of a midlife crisis or
a quarter life crisis
was actually accelerating not
just for me, but for everybody.
And that instead of
getting granted permission
for two of these in a lifetime,
that because our economy is
moving so quickly, and
particularly in tech,
and Silicon Valley, and
a company like Google,
we are going to be
asking and answering
what's next every few years.
And that actually, I
would expect nothing less.
So as I looked at how people
can be as agile as startups,
one of the things
I recognized was
that when we talk about startups
pivoting, it's often as plan
B. The original strategy
or direction has failed,
and the startup needs to
pivot to stay in business.
So just like YouTube used
to be a video dating site,
it pivoted to what it is today.
A multibillion dollar
part of the company.
But when it comes
to our careers,
pivot is the new
plan A. That when
I think about what it
takes to be successful,
pivot is really a mindset that
says, again, not that you have
to make drastic
career changes-- I'm
not here to say, oh, you
all need to leave tomorrow.
That's not it at all.
But it's asking,
how can I pivot?
How can I grow within my role?
How can I double down on
what's already working
and shift methodically
into something new?
As I started to understand, OK,
well, who is really doing this?
We hear about the
term "high net worth."
These are people who, over
the course of their lifetimes,
accrue a lot of
financial assets.
And so we call them high
net worth individuals.
Certainly, those
who work at Google,
at least for the
most part, and those
that I started
interviewing for my book--
I consider them high net growth.
These are people who really
value learning, growth,
and exploration.
And when given the choice,
they would make a lateral move
within the company.
They would take on a
10% project in addition
to what they're already doing.
They would bootstrap a business.
They would sacrifice in some
way, if needed, money in order
to keep pursuing their
learning and development.
And that when their personal
needs for growth are being met,
they then turn toward
making an impact.
So ultimately, I call
them impacters for short.
High net growth
individuals thrive when
they're learning and growing.
That's oxygen to them.
But it's not just
about me, me, me.
People who are high net
growth and, ultimately,
high net impact
also want to know
that the work they are
doing has an impact
on their team, on
clients, on the company,
on the broader community.
Google is ground zero for this.
That just the definition of
"Googliness," the people who
Google hires-- all of you
are so smart, and hungry,
and committed, and adaptable,
and all of these qualities
that you probably
don't even realize
how valuable they really are.
And so this idea
of hitting a pivot
point-- if you're
high net growth,
I would actually
expect nothing less.
And that, once again,
hitting these pivot points
within your role are
an opportunity to ask,
what's next?
And how can I make
the biggest impact?
I mentioned the shame and
blame that we see in our media
and in the culture,
particularly around millennials.
But I actually think
that it translates
to those of you working at
a company like Google, which
is that oh, you're
so entitled to want
more meaning in your work, or
to want to make a bigger impact.
That there's something wrong.
Well, actually, so much
is getting automated
and outsourced that I think
everybody is smart to say,
am I using my strengths
to the fullest?
Am I making the biggest
impact that I'm able?
And what are some small ways
that I can continue to do that
and to experiment?
We tend to think of growth
as a very linear process.
So we expect that if we
look at growth on the y-axis
and time on the x-axis,
we're going along,
and we think it's going to
be a straight line, kind of
like the old career
ladder paradigm.
That you're going to get a job
at Google, or get in a new role
here, or even just take on a
new set of responsibilities,
and it's like, OK, great.
Now I'm set.
I can coast.
But what ends up happening
is that our growth
tends to naturally taper
and we hit a pivot point.
At that point, as we
start to look ahead,
we either see a
plateau, and that's
just a general feeling
of I'm fine, work's fine,
things are OK-- you know, it's
a little sense of stagnation--
or an active decline.
That's where, if
you're in a role,
or have a set of
responsibilities that's just
really not a fit,
sometimes our bodies
will start sending signals.
Getting sick more
often than usual.
I had a friend who used
to get panic attacks when
she would get off the
subway on her way to work.
So that was a clear
sign her body is now
starting to ring alarm bells,
like you got to make a change.
So at this point, whether
we plateau or decline,
the choice is to pivot.
And by the way, if
you're a high net growth,
if you're an
impacter, studies show
that boredom has some of the
same physical manifestations
in the body as stress.
Increased heart rate,
increased cortisol levels.
And Tim Ferriss captures this
well in his book "The 4 Hour
Workweek."
He said the opposite of
happiness is boredom.
And that pretty much captures
the impact or sentiment.
So at this point the
choice is to pivot.
When you think about
a pivot, pivots
can be very small,
again, within your role,
or they can be larger.
And generally, the way
to measure a pivot--
and actually, I have to give
credit to Steve Maxwell,
because back in the day, Steve
was the best whiteboarder
I know.
And we would whiteboard things
like comfort zone and stretch
zone.
And so credit to Steve.
I've kind of rethought,
on the pivot axis,
what does it look
like when you're
taking on new responsibilities?
And so if you're in
your stagnation zone,
that's one thing.
It's a little hard to see here.
But this next level
is your comfort zone.
Then the optimal range
for change for impacters
is in your stretch zone,
where you feel challenged,
and it's edgy and exciting.
And then if you try and
turn too sharply, if you try
and pivot too quickly, it might
send you into your panic zone.
You can consider
this at any point,
not just with a bigger
pivot, but with any next step
or project that you're
going to take on.
When I have coaching clients
come to me, and they say,
I'm working at a big company
and I've hit a plateau,
my number one thing is to ask,
what can you do in your role?
I'm not the person that says,
oh, you should quit tomorrow.
I don't believe that.
I think that we're in
such a fluid economy now.
And I always look
and ask for them
to mine what's right in
front of them, what's
already under their feet.
So if I had said to any of
you, oh, the right thing
for you to do is to quit
tomorrow and start a business
from scratch, that
would probably
send you into a panic zone.
It's probably not
the right move.
I mean, maybe with
rare exception,
if you've already got that plan.
But really, the
goal of a pivot is,
what next steps within
your own career development
will keep you in
your stretch zone,
feeling engaged, and
challenged, and excited?
And so this is
something that you
can gauge as you go, with
anything that you're doing,
and also to look, where
am I playing it too safe?
Where am I hanging out
in my comfort zone?
Just so we're all
on the same page,
the way that I
define a career pivot
is a methodical shift in
a new related direction,
based on a foundation
of your strengths
and what's already working.
So it's not a 180.
If I had left Google to
become a yoga teacher,
that would have been a 180.
But instead, I was doing
coaching and career development
within Google, and I left
to do coaching and career
development on my own.
Even within Google, I was
doing adverts product training,
and then I did
CTI coach training
on nights and weekends,
and I pivoted internally.
When I did coach training, there
was no career development team.
It didn't exist.
But I pivoted onto it
once the team was formed.
So you can see
these are examples
of leveraging something
that was already working.
And this is really important,
and I will say the biggest
mistake that I made
during my self-employment
pivot was focusing
too much on what
I didn't want, what I didn't
know, what I didn't have.
And I think that
we inadvertently
do that sometimes.
When we vent to friends
and family about work,
it's what's bugging us.
But it's rare that people
stop and say what is working.
What are your strengths?
What are your interests?
What do you want?
What can you double down on?
So if you think of a pivot,
it's like a basketball player.
And this is the analogy
that came to me when
I was in my really tough spot,
which is that a basketball
player, when they
stop dribbling, they
plant both of their feet.
Then they have one
foot firmly rooted
and planted in the floor,
and that's their foundation,
and that gives them
strength and stability.
And then they can
scan for opportunity
with their pivot
foot instead of what
I was doing, which was
running around the basketball
court like a crazy person.
So the key of a pivot,
of how I define it,
which is different
than what we typically
hear in Silicon Valley,
is that a pivot always
involves having this plant foot
by doubling down on something
that's already working.
Before we go further,
I would love for you--
and if you're
watching on video this
is something you can reflect on.
But if you're in the
room, turn to someone
next to you and reverse
engineer a recent pivot,
specifically highlighting
what the thing in common was.
So to switch metaphors
for a moment,
think of it like a pole vaulter.
Whenever you pivot, there's this
pole, this point of leverage.
Then you slam it
into the ground,
and that's what catapults
you in this new direction.
So think about either a pivot
that you've done internally
at Google, or the pivot
that got you here,
and go out and share
with each other in pairs.
Because it's like
that you've already
done this, even if you didn't
have the language for it.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
All right.
Let's come back together.
I would love to
hear a few of these,
because it's really fun to hear
how you've already done this.
As Steve Jobs said in his
2005 commencement speech,
it's much easier to connect
the dots looking backward,
and reverse engineering
pivots is much the same way.
Like I said, you've
already done this.
And I'm actually
not here to tell you
something new or something
you don't already know,
I'm just giving you language
and a process to put around it.
So I would love to hear either
your pivot story within Google,
or what got you here, or
you can nominate a friend,
if they had a particularly
interesting one.
Anyone?
Don't be shy.
CLIFF: So I'll start
off and then see
if someone else
is likewise moved.
Yeah, for me, at least,
it was volunteering
on the Talks at Google
program, like leading tours
for the visiting
speakers, trying
to find a need there
based on something
that I was already doing.
And then like you said,
perfecting that skill,
and then expanding to
the rest of the business,
and starting up
the Talks program.
JENNY BLAKE: Cliff's a great
example of starting something
small as an experiment,
and then later, it
grows into a full time role.
Which is much more common and
doable than you might think.
Steve.
STEVE: Hello.
JENNY BLAKE: Hello.
STEVE: So my most recent switch
was from a learning business
partner role into managing
the learning programs overall.
And the pivot was--
I mean, it's still
in learning and
development, but I
realized I was actually trying
to do a whole bunch of problem
solving from the learning
partner role, which
was actually the job of
the person who was running
the learning program.
JENNY BLAKE: Interesting.
STEVE: So I was already trying
to solve their problems,
and then the position
opened up, and so it just
seemed very natural to so
sort of move into that.
JENNY BLAKE: That's
so interesting.
So you doubled down on
what you were already
doing within the role.
STEVE: Right, and what I
knew was a deeper skill
set that I hadn't
been using recently,
but I'd had from
20 years earlier
that I developed
deeply in college.
JENNY BLAKE: That's
so interesting.
I heard so many people
who say once they
find that next iteration of
either their existing role
or their new one, they say, oh,
it feels like my whole career
has been preparing me for this.
And I love hearing
about latent strengths.
Strengths in waiting or in
hiding that you're not fully
using, but you look
back and you think, oh,
duh, I've had this 20 years.
That's how I felt.
I just trained
a group of pivot coaches, and it
was the first time in 5 and 1/2
years I was doing
coach training again,
which I used to do with Becky
here at Google for Career Guru.
And it was this deep source
of joy that came back to me.
It just came flooding in like,
oh, I've done this before
and I can do this.
And so I encourage
all of you to think
about strengths in waiting,
strengths in hiding,
even things that you
enjoyed doing as a kid.
I know that's a little cliche in
the career space at this point,
we hear it all the time,
but it really is true.
There are so many clues in
what you've already done.
If I only leave you
with one thing today,
it's that the answer
to what's next
is already under your feet.
You're already doing it in
some way, you already know it.
It's not so far
outside of yourself.
So let's look at how to
actually unpack this.
I developed a four
stage pivot method
because, as anyone who did
work with me here knows,
I really love structure, and
templates, and organization.
And one of my favorite
guiding mantras in life
comes from the practice
of agile development.
And they have this phrase,
each time you repeat a task,
take one step toward
automating it.
And I felt like, well,
if every time one of us
impacters or high net growth
individuals-- if every time we
hit a pivot point, we
start asking what's next,
and then we are driving
ourselves crazy,
and taking it personally,
and beating ourselves
up, and feeling ashamed that
we feel that way-- well,
that's really inefficient.
And that bugs me.
So how can we get better
at asking and answering
what's next?
The pivot method is
my unpacking of that,
and both reverse
engineering my moves,
and interviewing
hundreds of people,
and doing coaching for
the last eight years.
It's a four stage
process that really
starts from that
basketball player analogy.
So this is where we'll
get a little interactive.
The first stage is plant.
This is the one that
most people want to skip.
Especially if you're a
problem solving go-getter,
like everybody is here,
the natural reaction
is, I've hit a pivot
point, what's next?
What's out there?
The first thing most
people want to do
is start looking
outside of themselves.
And what ends up happening is
you're scanning without a plan.
You're looking
for the next thing
without being
grounded, without being
rooted in this plant foot.
So it ends up taking longer,
it feels more stressful,
you might feel overwhelmed
by choices, feel compare
and despair, or
analysis paralysis.
These are the kinds
of things that happen
when we skip the plant stage.
So number one is,
what's already working?
If you look at this graph,
it's what are your values?
What's most important to you?
What are your strengths?
I love how Steve's example
is about what are you
doing within your role
that might not even
be in the job description,
but that people
keep coming to you for, or that
you keep working your way to?
When does time fly?
When are you the
most in the zone?
What is working within your
role, whether that's 95% or 5%?
Identify it.
And this can also be
outside of work too.
What do you enjoy
doing on the side?
What do you do for fun?
My friend, Neil, wrote a
book called "The Happiness
Equation," and he says, what's
your Saturday morning test?
What do you do on
Saturday mornings
when you don't feel like you
need to be doing anything else?
And the second most critical
part about planting is vision.
I don't believe in
asking, where do
you see yourself in five years?
I think that question is totally
irrelevant at this point.
Who of us could have said where
we would be five years ago?
Things are moving much too
quickly for that, and certainly
at Google.
I know when I was
here, we were reorging
as much as we were orging.
So there's nobody
better at dealing
with chaos and
uncertainty than you,
and sitting at the edge of that.
But I do think we can
say a one year vision.
So one year from now, what
does success look like?
What would you be thrilled to
have happening in your role?
What does your ideal
average day look like?
What kind of impact do you
want to have on your team,
on your clients
within the company,
on the company as a whole,
on the broader community?
These are all
questions that help,
I call it in the
book, put a pin in it.
So just like in Google Maps,
you know where you're starting,
and now you've got
to put a pin in it.
And the reason a lot of
people skip this is, one,
it seems kind of fuzzy.
And for some, it might
be a little too soft.
But it's really important.
The other reason people skip it
is often our gremlins rush in.
So as soon as we say something
truly exciting, what I really
want to be doing a year
from now, it might say,
you're not good enough,
smart enough, capable enough.
That's not possible.
It's harder to move internally
than it is to get a job.
Like all the can'ts, or the
shoulds, or even the how.
How are you going to do that?
I don't know if any of you have
had this experience that you
tell a friend or family member
of something really exciting
that you want to do,
and they immediately
start peppering you with hows.
How are you going to do that?
How are you going to find that?
How are you going to
have time for that?
And so it kind of
starts to shoot it down
before the vision
is even developed.
When we're doing coach
training, I often describe this.
The vision, it starts as a
black and white photograph,
and the work here is in
blowing it up to a 3D movie.
The more vivid that movie,
that vision, the more clearly,
the more effectively,
and the more efficiently
you can scan for
opportunities for what's next.
So now just take a moment.
And in fact, we'll just
give, let's say, 30 seconds,
even with your eyes closed.
And think about what you're
currently enjoying most
and what's working best.
Because I know not everyone
has a pen and paper,
which is a real throwback.
And now start to reflect
on what does success
look like a year from now?
So a year from now, how
do you want to feel?
And again, I encourage
you to close your eyes.
If you're watching on video, you
can definitely jot things down
on paper and pause.
What does smashing success
looks like a year from now?
I encourage you to spend
much more time on this.
When I'm work with
coaching clients,
sometimes I spend a month or
more on each of these stages.
We're doing 30
seconds, which is just
the tiniest tip of the iceberg.
But you start to get a sense
for how to work yourself
through this process.
And I also encourage you,
if you do this later,
don't stop brainstorming.
Keep going.
Go for your stretch zone.
It's often the case that
when I say, what does success
look like a year
from now, people
give me something pretty safe.
What feels reasonable.
And I encourage you not to do
that at these early stages.
Instead, go for quantity.
Write down as much as you can.
And then later, you'll get
a chance to narrow it down.
The next stage is that
once you're rooted,
so once you know where you are
and where you want to end up,
these form the
brackets of your pivot.
And now we have a
much clearer picture
of this gap between
where you are now,
where you want to end up,
and how to bridge the two.
And the way to bridge this
gap is through people, skills,
and projects.
So we're rooted in our plant.
So based on your strengths
and your one year vision,
now we can look for people,
skills, and projects
that are connected to that.
So the scanning is anchored.
So the people.
Who do you admire?
Who can you connect with?
Who is doing what
you want to be doing?
I like, again, to
use Steve's example.
Someone had this role that
he was really interested in,
and when the role
opened up, he knew
he was perfectly
positioned to move into it.
And this can be within the
company or outside of it.
These mentors can be friendtors.
Friends of yours who you can
brainstorm, and collaborate,
and connect with.
They can also be
mentors from afar.
It's perfectly fine if you
want to say Larry Page,
and you look to him to
see, what is he doing?
How does he manage
his next move?
Or even podcasts, books.
There are so many ways that
you can learn from people
that it doesn't all
have to be people
with in your direct access.
Skills.
Usually when we're here
and we want to get here,
there is a skill gap.
And that's exciting.
That's the whole point of
wanting to plan our next move.
How can I learn and grow?
That feeds our
soul as impacters.
So what do you want to learn?
What do you want to
become an expert in?
Get strategic about what skills,
if you were to develop them
further, would most help you
move from where you are now
to where you want to go.
I mentioned, while we
were fixing the slides,
that when I applied
to the job at Google,
I was absolutely terrified
to speak in front of people.
And I mentioned I got red hives
all over my chest and neck.
So I applied for the
training team role
because I knew
that that skill set
of being in front of the
room, and somehow trying
to remain calm, and
not embarrass myself
with my physiological
response, would be a good asset
to have some day.
And that's what's allowing
me to be here now, and not
be freaking out, and not
be wearing a turtleneck.
So skills is important.
And then projects.
Then you can start
to narrow down
projects that are going
to be, again, based
on what you identified
in the plant stage,
exciting to move into.
So I know we're doing this
all in our head at the moment,
but close your eyes for another
30-- we'll do a minute total,
but 30 seconds on,
who do you admire?
So based on your
one year vision,
who's currently doing
things that are interesting
to you, either within the
company or outside of it?
And who might you talk to?
Who could you
schedule lunch with?
OK.
So scanning is about
seeing what's out there.
And then the third stage, pilot.
So this will be near and dear
to your heart as Googlers.
Certainly, I share
so many stories
of Googlers in the book.
And so much of my
philosophy around
applying pivoting
to career comes
from what I learned
at Google, and what
I learned both doing training,
and then later moving
into coaching
career development.
Pilot.
We talk about pilots
all the time at Google.
Pilot programs, pilot launches.
So it's a way to test an
idea and see how it goes.
I mentioned in the
book there's a chapter,
it's called "Get Scrappy."
So we know, and I
directly say this
is something I learned at
Google, launch and iterate.
And what's different is
applying that to career.
Because a lot of people
put pressure on themselves,
when they think about
career development,
to have the next huge move.
And there's so much pressure.
And when we're thinking on
the old paradigm of the career
ladder, there's
a lot of pressure
to try and magically jump
from one rung all the way up
to the next.
But instead, if you can think
about career pilots, smaller
experiments, think about
your own personal 10% or 20%
projects in your career, then
you could be much more agile.
So I mentioned that I like to
use the analogy of your career
as a smartphone.
So your education
and your upbringing
is you're out of the box model.
Then it's up to you to download
apps for different skills,
interests, and experiences
that are exciting to you,
just like what we've done in
the plant and scan stages.
Well, piloting is all
about downloading an app.
Becky and I downloaded
an app, which
was a 10% project
of trying to build
this drop in coaching program
with a whole team of people
early on.
Cliff had an app of volunteering
to manage talks when it was not
at all your full time role.
It was just a small
passion project.
And even doing campus tours
is a really interesting career
pilot.
So I encourage you
to think about,
how can you now
test what hypotheses
you've come up with in
the plant and scan stages
based on your strengths?
So it all should build from what
you've looked at previously.
And a good pilot, a
good career pilot,
will test what I
call the three E's.
One, do I enjoy this new area?
Two, can I become an expert
at it, and do I want to?
And three, is there
room to expand?
So for example, when I
went to coach training,
I knew I enjoyed it.
I couldn't believe that my
bookshelves had come to life
and there was a
room full of people
that were interested
in talking about things
like human potential
and fulfillment in life.
OK.
Expertise.
Could I become an expert?
Who knows?
But I was willing to
try, and invest in that,
and feel really
awkward and nervous.
I used to be sick to my stomach
before coaching sessions,
because I was just nervous.
But I kept pushing through that.
And then expansion.
At that time, there
was not a role for me
to be a coach
within the company.
But by continuing,
it built naturally.
I share Seth Marbin's
story in the book.
Seth started GoogleServe as a
response to a Google culture
idea call out one year.
And the first year, he had
7,000 people from 40 countries,
and it was over one day.
The following year,
he doubled it.
He had 14,000 volunteers
from 70 countries,
and it was a full week.
And then over the years, again,
there was no role at the time,
but he ended up pitching a role
managing Google's volunteer
outreach full time.
So that's a great example of
you know you're enjoying it,
he's becoming better at it,
he's proving the market.
So even within the
company, proving the market
need, and that,
hey, this can really
make an impact on the business.
And then it grew
naturally from there.
So now take 30 seconds,
and think about,
what experiments could
you run in the next month?
So based on the
skills, and the people,
and the strengths that
you've already identified,
think about-- this is kind of
comfort zone to stretch zone.
OK?
And a career pilot
could even just
be having lunch with someone.
So they don't all have
to be massive projects.
OK.
Close your eyes,
take 20 more seconds
to brainstorm on this one.
Small experiments.
Go for quantity, not
quality at this point.
Now think about in
the next six months.
What would fall in
your stretch zone?
Reconnect with your
one your vision.
What pilots would most move
you toward that one year vision
that you identified that you
could run in the next six
months?
OK, time.
Again, you could spend a
whole lot longer on these.
This is really
fun to brainstorm.
So I encourage you to, again,
go for quantity over quality.
Think about things
in your stretch zone.
Think of what would move
you closest to your one year
vision.
And know that pivot is a cycle.
So you can plant, scan,
pilot over and over,
and be perfectly happy.
In fact, you could
do this for years.
And this is a way to
frame career development,
that there doesn't
necessarily have
to be this fourth
stage, which we'll get
to in a minute, of launching.
But you can continuously be
plant, scanning, and piloting.
You could continuously say,
every quarter, what's working?
What can I double down on?
What's out there?
What do I want to learn?
Great.
What pilots can I run?
And I love metaphors,
so if you think
about pilots like race
horses at the Kentucky Derby,
they're like race horses
at the starting gate.
And eventually, one of
them will pull ahead,
but we don't know which one.
I mean, even for me. "PIVOT"
just launched last week,
and I've been working on
this book for three years.
It's my own pivot point.
And people are inevitably
going to ask, what's next,
which triggered my first
existential crisis when
my first book came out.
And the truth is I don't know.
I really don't.
I have pilots, I have
ideas, I have hypotheses,
but I actually have no clue
which of my income stream
race horses is
going to take off.
And so part of, again, what
you're so good at already,
being in the Google culture,
is being OK with that.
And it's one of
the biggest things
that I learned
writing this book.
From the time I interviewed
people to a year and a half
later when I went to
fact check, almost nobody
had stayed in the same
place, both by choice
and by circumstance.
People got hired, fired,
their companies got acquired,
then they got fired,
they quit their jobs,
they started their own business,
they hated their own business,
so they went back to a job.
I mean, I saw it all.
I saw it all.
And even within Google, we know
that things change so quickly.
And you think you're in one
role, or then your manager
changes, or the company, the
org changes, or the building
changes, or you go work
in an office abroad.
So there's so much going on.
And you can always
be looking at,
what do I want to
double down on?
What is working, and
how can I do more of it?
Sometimes there is
a launch moment.
So that's when you go all
in on a new direction.
My editor and I were very clear.
We actually took out
the word leap, which
this used to be called leap.
And we realized that when
you follow the pivot method,
it's not a leap anymore.
It's not a blind
leap, it's not a jump.
That you're reducing risk by
piloting, so that by the time
you do go all in on something,
you take a new role,
you move to another team, you
do go work in an office abroad,
you're more clear.
There's less risk.
It hasn't sent you
into your panic zone.
You have very methodically
worked your way
into that launch, where
it becomes really clear.
And of course,
there will still be
some uncertainty and
some fear, but nobody
that I talked to regretted
their launch decision,
no matter what their
move was, which
I found really interesting.
So I say in the book that
if you're an impacter,
we don't have
FOMO, we have FONT.
Fear of not trying.
That ultimately,
our biggest fear
is to have an idea
about ways to better
leverage our strengths
to make a bigger impact--
our biggest fear is not to try.
So ultimately, when you're
ready to launch, a lot of people
ask, well, how do I know
when I'm ready to launch?
It's when you know that you
would rather try and fail--
which what does that
even mean-- than not try
and stay in the same place.
So we didn't use paper, so
there's nothing to circle.
But I would love for you
to now turn in pairs.
These are two of my
favorite questions.
You can ask them of
yourself on any project.
You could even use the
pivot method on projects
that you're stuck on.
But consider, and turn
to someone next to you,
and just share one small step
you can take in the next week,
based on everything that
you were reflecting on.
And what next step would
make the biggest impact?
And these can be
professional or personal.
For some people, their skill is
like cooking or salsa dancing,
and that would be an app they
want to download and feel
fulfilled.
So go ahead and share in pairs,
then we'll do some as a group.
Great.
OK.
In the interest of
time, we'll keep moving,
but I encourage
you to share these.
Ask each other.
It's also one of my
favorite questions
now when I meet new people, and
even talking to other Googlers,
to ask about their
pivots internally
or what they're
thinking about next.
This can also be used as
a conversation framework.
So a lot of times when people
come to us and they're stuck,
they may say, oh, I just
don't know what I should do,
our first instinct is to
jump to giving advice.
But actually, that
sort of robs them
of facilitating their
own thought process
and being the expert
in their own life.
So you could even apply pivot as
a conversation framework, where
you say, well, what is working?
What do you want?
What's out there?
What can you try?
What's a small next
step you can take?
And you can see that's
less than a minute.
So you can do this in as little
as 10 minutes with someone.
And so I encourage you--
that's also a nice way
to try having conversations
with other people,
to frame it up in a really
strengths based approach.
One of my favorite quotes
is from poet David White,
who says, that which you can
plan is too small for you
to live.
One of the things that I
feel most passionate about
is just to release you all of
the pressure to have to know,
in perfect specificity,
what's next.
And that, actually,
you don't need to.
And if you did,
you would be bored.
And that even Eric Schmidt
and Jonathan Rosenberg,
in their book "How
Google Works"--
they talk about smart creatives,
and that we do all this work
to bring in smart
creatives, and then
they inevitably want to
change, and shift, and grow.
They say still fight
like hell to keep them.
And I love that perspective.
That it's like, why
did we expect anything
less of anyone in this
room than to feel this way?
That that which you can plan
is too small for you to live.
So as uncomfortable as the
uncertainty can be sometimes,
I wish I could convey that it is
such a ninja skill that you're
all developing.
That as I did the
research, and what
does it really take to be most
agile in a modern economy, one
of the things is the ability
to handle uncertainty.
If you work at Google, check.
Another is openness
and willingness
to try new technology.
Once again, check.
The third, we're moving
from knowledge workers
to relationship workers.
That actually, we're at
peak data, peak information,
peak content online.
And that with
automation, and robots,
and outsourcing,
that the real value
is in becoming relationship
workers, collaborating.
Once again, check.
You have everything
that you need.
And if you've hit a pivot point
in your role at the company,
you're human.
You're human, this
is to be expected,
and that should be celebrated.
And again, it doesn't
mean that these
have to be big drastic changes.
But something I'm
so passionate about
is just giving us
new language that's
gender neutral and
judgment neutral.
So pivot.
It doesn't have to be a crisis.
One of my personal mottos that
I've adopted is build first,
then your courage will follow.
I came to realize that courage
doesn't drop down from the sky.
When we want to make a move,
sometimes we're waiting.
Oh, when I feel
courageous enough,
I'll do this next thing,
I'll approach my manager
about this idea that I have.
But actually, it works
the opposite way.
That when we just start
taking small steps,
and planting seeds, and running
pilots pretty much on faith,
not knowing what's
going to work,
but trusting that if we keep
trying these small experiments,
something will click,
that's when we really
start to feel progress.
And in taking those steps, we
start to feel more courageous.
And that actually, fear,
insecurity, and uncertainty
are the biggest doorways of
opportunity that we have.
So when you feel those things,
when you're asking what's next,
you can stop taking
it personally
and know that you're
absolutely on the right track,
and that in asking
those questions,
the answers will come.
And that you don't have to have
every next step mapped our.
The only move that
matters is your next one.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for having me.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
JENNY BLAKE: And if you want to
learn more, there's the book,
and I have a "PIVOT"
podcast, and there's
a full toolkit online.
I have about 40 templates
for things like ideal day,
knowns and unknowns,
pilot brainstorming.
That's all at
pivotmethod.com/toolkit.